♪ (SOUNDWAVE) ♪
SPEAKER: Money isn't everything.
MARIAN BROOK: It is
when you haven't got it.
ALICIA MALONE: Yes, money was
everything in the Gilded Age.
Well, as long as it was
the right kind of money.
Hello, I'm Alicia Malone.
I'm a host on
Turner Classic Movies,
and that means I know a lot
about film history.
But American history? I mean,
with this accent, not so much.
That's where
my co-host comes in.
TOM MEYERS: (CHUCKLES)
I love your accent.
Hi, I'm Tom Meyers. I'm from
the Bowery Boys History Podcast,
which is all about
New York City history,
including that exciting time
in the late 19th century
that we call the Gilded Age.
♪ (ORCHESTRAL MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
ALICIA:
Well, this The Gilded Age
is a new HBO original series
created by Julian Fellowes
and it's a drama that's set
in late 1800s New York,
where a social war is raging
between new money and old.
And after each episode,
you can join us
as we discuss what happened
on the screen.
TOM: And also discuss
how the show incorporates
real people and places
and events
from New York in the 1880s,
because so many of the things
that we're going to see
on the show really happened.
The power struggles
within New York's high society,
but also changes
that took place in the city.
Changes in transportation
and technology.
Even changing tastes
in architecture.
We're going to be going inside
some really lavish mansions.
ALICIA: Ooh, yeah. We get to see
some lavish dinner parties.
-The food!
-(TOM SIGHS)
And those really
happened too, I'm sure.
TOM: Oh, yes, they did.
And you'd better
watch your manners, Alicia,
because Mrs. Astor is watching.
ALICIA: Oh, no. (CHUCKLES)
Well, we'll also be joined
by some of the cast and crew
who bring this show to life.
The directors and
the costume designers and more.
TOM: With exclusive
behind the scenes interviews
and fun-filled history,
our new podcast will be
the ultimate look
inside the new series,
and inside
the Gilded Age itself.
SPEAKER 2: This is
a great city in a great country,
at a great time in our history.
I want to be part of it.
ALICIA: And you can be
part of it if you subscribe now
to the official
Gilded Age Podcast.
TOM: Our first podcast episode
becomes available
after the series premiere
on HBO and HBO Max,
on Monday, January 24th.
♪ (MUSIC SWELLS) ♪